- What do we have here?
I have "The Delphian Course,"
10 volume set, first edition,
which was printed in 1901.
RICK: This is really cool.
Where did you guys get these?
We got them at a swap meet.
So obviously you guys
shop at the same store.
[laughing]
ERIC: We came to
the pawn shop today
to sell our "Delphian Course."
This particular set
was a liberal arts
education for women.
DEREK: It's
definitely a cool set.
ERIC: It looked great on
my bookshelf for years.
[laughing]
We tend to move a lot
more than we used to,
and to lug around from place to
place is just too much to bear.
[chuckle]
RICK: Back late
1800s, early 1900s,
publishers were making
lots of sets of books
like this, because
it was a way people
could get educated without
going to college, you know?
Basically they were
like book clubs--
Oh.
RICK: --and Delphian
was for women.
Say you live in a small town.
You know, your husband worked,
you took care of the kids,
but you're going to
read a book at night.
And one day a week,
your club met.
They had intellectual
discussions
and they talked about what
they read about that week.
It was a social thing, and
you get to learn something.
These cover just
about everything.
It was a really
liberal arts thing.
Medieval stories, history
of music, conduct of life.
This set of books, you know,
would last you for years.
By the time you were done,
you had a much broader
understanding of the world.
It was a great
thing for the time.
[music playing]
So what do you want
to do with them?
I want to sell them.
I'm tired of moving them around.
[laughing]
- Books can get heavy, yes.
- Yes.
[laughing]
How much do you want for them?
$250.
[pained sigh]
I know the second
edition sold for $150.
[exhale]
That person was really lucky.
[laughing]
Just because something
is a first edition
doesn't mean it's worth
a lot of money, OK?
When you talk about volumes like
encyclopedia sets and volumes
like this, they just
don't sell well.
I would give you
50 bucks for it.
Hm.
Could you go $100?
RICK: No.
Ah.
They're nice books
and everything,
but they're just not that
collectible, plain and simple.
Would you do $60, because
that's easier to split?
Were you guys bad
in math, or something?
Yes.
[laughing]
I'll give you 50 bucks.
That's it.
OK, deal.
All right.
RICK: Cool, man.
Thanks.
RICK: All right,
let's go up here.
I'll write you up.
Thanks.
ERIC: Made 50 bucks today.
We're going to go
have a nice dinner.
DEREK: I saw a really nice print
I want to buy that's $60, so--
and you can't split
that, can you?
No.
You'll probably win.
As always.